I just feel like you've heard me say
this so many times everything in your
life is your own fault
if you get screwed over in a business
deal I will say that's your own fault
because you should have read the
contract
you should have paid more attention to
the note like honestly honestly like
I've had I've had points for like I had
an employee spend too much on my credit
card right like with stupid amount more
and it was gonna fall because I wasn't
watching like it's it's your everything
in life's your own fault like did they
did they look at the tax form no did
they Google if Bitcoin or whatever on
taxes no they're like oh it's just
easier okay